i said i wasn't going to post another
video about sunscreen but
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and skincare nerd
and serial sunscreen video maker in case
you haven't already heard the 2021
version of this anti-cancer product is
actually giving you cancer
is that there's been benzene found in a
bunch of sunscreens
how much should we be freaking out about
this i did an instagram post on this
already
but i thought i'd elaborate a bit more
in a video
like subscribe notification bell you
know the drill first let's talk about
the results before we go into some of
the more
questionable things about this report
it's from valley shaw a us-based online
pharmacy that brands themselves as the
pharmacy that checks the premise is the
fda doesn't regulate drugs as closely as
valley shore would like so
valley shore test them before they sell
them so valley shore bought a bunch of
products and sent them to some labs for
testing using gas chromatography
it was sunscreen and after sun care
products from 294 batches from 69
different brands they found benzene at
low pass per million concentrations in
78 of these
most of them were spray sunscreens there
was over 2 parts per million in 14
different batches between 0.1 and 2
parts per million and 26
and the rest were below 0.1 parts per
million for reference two parts per
million is one one fiftieth of a drop in
a product this big
and one three hundredth of a drop in a
product this big they pick two parts per
million because that's the limit that
the fda recommends for
products like hand sanitizers and
medications the table in attachment a
also has a list of sunscreens where they
didn't detect any benzene
i've seen a lot of stuff online about
this that just isn't quite right so
let's clear up a few things
firstly no one is purposely adding
benzene to products benzene doesn't
really have a purpose in cosmetics it's
not a fragrance
it doesn't absorb uv strongly enough to
be used as a sunscreen
it's not a preservative it has no
beneficial function that can't be done
more safely and cheaply with a different
ingredient
benzene is a trace contaminant so it's
in there because it was an impurity
in another ingredient or something
happened during the manufacturing
process
it's also not an issue that's specific
to sunscreens there was benzene found in
after sun care products in that highest
group and
this was an issue that was in hand
sanitizers in an earlier report
it's not because of particular sunscreen
ingredients or chemical sunscreens
both mineral and chemical sunscreens
show up on the list valley shul also
checked raw sunscreen ingredients for
benzene and they didn't find any
there are some sunscreen ingredients
that sort of look like the word benzene
but
they don't have anything to do with
benzene sort of like how lady gaga
doesn't have much to do with galileo
it also isn't a problem with particular
brands all of the brands tested that had
high benzene also had products with no
benzene
except for the one brand that only had
one product tested it's also not
specific to particular products
all of the products where they tested
more than one batch had different levels
of benzene so it seems like sometimes
when the brand made the product there
was more benzene
and then sometimes when they made it
there was less so if you want to find
out if your product has benzene in it
you don't just match the name of the
product you also want to match
the other parts of the table the upc lot
and expiry date
there are also 4 lists so make sure
you're looking at the right list
if it says nd that means they didn't
detect benzene
but how worried should we actually be
about benzene
there are two phrases in the report that
i think were misinterpreted and they
make benzene sound a lot scarier than it
actually is
benzene is a known human carcinogen and
there's no safe level of benzene
and it kind of sounds like anyone who's
used one of these sunscreens has
upped their chances of cancer by a lot
but that's not really true
known human carcinogen is a
classification from the iarc
these classifications known probable and
possible human carcinogen tell us about
how certain the evidence is that
something
increases the chance of cancer it
doesn't tell us how big
that increase actually is so some things
that are really potent are in the same
category as things that are a lot weaker
for example we know that walking near a
dog definitely increases your risk of
getting bitten by a dog
so does punching a dog so they're both
known dog bite causes
but obviously one of these is much worse
we can see this in action by looking at
some of the other known carcinogens so
smoking cigarettes and eating processed
meat i think we all know there's a
massive difference
in the risk from smoking cigarettes
versus eating a few slices of salami
and on top of that i think we all know
there's a big difference between smoking
one cigarette when you were 16
and smoking 30 cigarettes a day for 50
years you might remember from my video
about clean beauty the idea of hazards
versus risks
these classifications are hazard-based
if you haven't watched that check it out
it really puts the idea of toxic
chemicals in your beauty products into
perspective
the other phrase that i think got taken
out of context is that there's
probably no safe level of benzene
combined with known human carcinogen i
think it really makes it sound like any
exposure to benzene
is dangerous but if you look at the rest
of the sentence in this toxicology
context
safe means absolutely zero effect
no safe level means that little
exposures can add up
but the question is how much is the
benzene in sunscreen adding to the
amount of benzene we're already getting
a few of us pointed out on instagram
that we're actually exposed to quite a
lot of benzene in our everyday lives
so we need to think about that to
contextualize how much extra we're
getting from the benzene in sunscreens
we mostly get benzene by inhaling it so
for example in petrol or gasoline if
you're american
there's one to three percent benzene so
we can compare it more easily that's ten
to thirty thousand parts per million
cigarette smoke and bushfires also have
benzene also indoor air
there's tiny bits of benzene that's left
over in manufacturing plastics and stuff
that get released into the air over time
we also eat it in food and it's in
drinking water but these amounts that we
get in everyday life
aren't enough to lead to cancer the link
to cancer is with much higher amounts so
usually with industrial exposure where
workers are working with benzene every
day
for most of us we inhale 3 to 40
micrograms per cubic meter of air
and this is about a thousand times lower
than the amount that's been found to be
problematic and linked to cancer
now for skin contact like we'd get with
sunscreens unfortunately there's a lot
less information
that's because the main concern with
benzene is industrial exposure and most
industrial exposure is from inhaling it
benzene is volatile which means most of
it actually evaporates before it has a
chance to get through your skin
into your body how much gets through
your skin really depends on what the
benzene is in
but in general it's a fraction of a
percent of the amount that you apply
and not all of the stuff that gets
through the skin actually makes it to
the rest of your body
one paper estimated that a worker who
puts their hands and lower half of their
forearms in one thousand parts per
million benzene for one hour a day
and their skin is damaged so it's going
to absorb more than normal
then over 40 years they'd have a
relative risk of leukemia of 1.42
so that means they're one and a half
times more likely to develop leukemia
compared to someone who didn't have this
exposure to benzene but
if this was a hundred parts per million
instead then there would be close to no
increased risk of leukemia so 100 parts
per million was the limit recommended
for workers
in sunscreens the highest amount was six
parts per million so
based on the evidence it doesn't really
seem like six parts per million is going
to make that much of a difference
joe schwartz chemistry professor and
professional debunker thinks that
there's an infinitesimal chance that the
benzene in sunscreen will lead to any
significant amount in blood
don't get me wrong benzene is definitely
harmful there's no benefit to it i'm not
recommending that you slather yourself
on purpose with lots of benzene we
should be reducing our exposure to
things like benzene and it's a good
thing that regulators are working on it
but like with other harmful and
hazardous things
our risk depends on our exposure the
harm depends on how much you get and how
you're exposed to it
and this aspect gets lost a lot of the
time when we're talking about scary
things on our beauty products i've
talked about this in the context of
dirty lists from clean beauty companies
but this sort of scary story has been
happening for a long time before clean
beauty for example there was a big thing
about lead and lipstick in like the late
90s early 2000s
there are trace amounts of lead and
lipstick and there's nothing beneficial
about lead
but the amounts and lipstick are so tiny
that they're not going to have any
real effect on your health there are a
few things in the valley shore report
that i think
are a bit confusing so for example the
dermatologist that they quoted as an
expert
says there is not a safe level of
benzene that can exist in sunscreen
products and even benzene at 0.1 parts
per million
in sunscreen could expose people to
excessively high nanogram amounts of
benzene
i think this doesn't really reflect what
we know about the toxicology of benzene
for example in the eu benzene is allowed
in some cosmetic ingredients as an
impurity if it's below 1000 parts per
million
to make it below 0.1 plus per million
these ingredients would have to be used
at less than 100 of a percent
and these ingredients are used at much
higher concentrations than that
the excessively high nanogram amounts of
benzene bit is also really weird because
we're normally exposed to much higher
amounts that we measure in micrograms
not nanograms
a 2010 paper estimated that non-smokers
inhale about 200 to 450 micrograms
or 200 000 to 450 000 nanograms of
benzene a day
and again this amount is really tiny
compared to the industrial exposures
that were actually linked to cancer
there's also a really scientifically er
comparison in the report there's another
not very nice substance called
ndma not mdma that's been found in some
pills
and the fda has limited that to two
parts per million as well
this translates to 96 nanograms a day so
they use this as a comparable benchmark
to the amount of benzene you get from
sunscreen if you apply four shot glasses
with two parts per million
this comparison is really whack for a
number of reasons so
obviously we apply a lot more sunscreen
than a tablet-sized amount
so if they were allowed at the same
concentration then benzene is obviously
a lot safer
like if you compare one caffeine tablet
to four shot glasses of caffeine tablets
the thing you can throw back four shots
of is obviously going to be a lot safer
and of course it's also a completely
different route of exposure we swallow
tablets we don't swallow sunscreen
well i'm not going to assume i know what
you do with your life but
it's a silly comparison there's also the
disposal recommendations so valley sure
recommend that you dispose of the
benzene sunscreens as hazardous waste
but as this environmental scientist who
works with hazardous waste points out it
is a really tiny amount of benzene 1
300th of a drop in a tube this size
hazardous waste people are probably not
going to know what to say if you ask
them about it
the fact that sunscreen sprays are
flammable is probably a bigger safety
issue
again i think benzene is harmful and i'm
not saying that you shouldn't reduce
your exposure to it but hopefully this
gives you some context for how worried
you should be
if you've been using one of these
sunscreens or if you're using a
sunscreen that hasn't been tested
also it's good to remember that benzene
in personal care products has never been
linked to cancer
but uv exposure has i would personally
probably stop using
products from the batches that were
measured to have higher amounts i would
probably still hold on to them though in
case we get more information or if
there's a recall
will the fda actually issue a recall
well i think joe schwartz is right it's
not really scientifically justified but
the government does a lot of things that
aren't scientifically justified
save sunscreens check out my video on
clean beauty if you haven't already i
also have tons of other videos about
sunscreens
thanks to steven for helping me with
this video also wasabi.jiff for her
insights check them both out on
instagram if you haven't already
next video is definitely not sunscreen